bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et dans cette émission cap
sur la coop 21
l'europe unie pour la protection de
l'environnement à paris l'union propose
de réduire ses gaz à effet de serre de
40% d'ici à 2030 et de 50% d'ici à 2050
par rapport aux niveaux de 1990 des
niveaux qui manque d'ambition selon les
écologistes européens
en seconde partie notre reportage sur
les lobby de l'automobile au sein même
du parlement européen françois moulin
est parti enquêter volkswagen mercedes
renault psa site vous allez le voir
assez stupéfiant l' influence de
l'industrie automobile et directe dans
la fabrication même des textes de loi
enfin l'actualité c'est aussi la turquie
qui revient en grâce à bruxelles déroule
le tapis rouge à ahmet davutoglu
c'est le premier ministre turc il boit
du petit lait à la turquie obtient une
relance du processus d'adhésion à
l'union en échange ankara s'engage à
retenir les migrants sur son territoire
on critique beaucoup l'europe ces
derniers temps mais l'europe est quand
même aux avant-postes en matière de
protection de l'environnement sur
l'objectif de réduction des gaz à effet
de serre on est en avance en europe 1
l'objectif c'était moins 20 % de gaz
d'ici à 2020
aujourd'hui en 2015 on en est déjà à
-23% pour la coop 21 c'est un tandem qui
parle au nom de l'union avec des
objectifs bien précis regarder
un homme et une femme à la coop 21
l'europe s'affiche en tandem pour
défendre la protection de
l'environnement
c'est la ministre luxembourgeoise de
l'environnement carole 10 gourdes qui
porte la voix de l'union aux côtés du
commissaire européen climat l'espagnol
miguel cagnes et et leur mission
négocier au nom des 28 ministres une
feuille de route qui prévoit des mesures
contraignantes
les belles promesses ne suffisent plus
il nous faut un accord contraignant
solide durable
l'europe unie pour sauver la planète pas
si vite des 28 ont eu bien du mal à se
mettre d'accord entre eux pas facile de
satisfaire les intérêts de tout le monde
la pologne et la slovaquie qui défendent
bec et ongles leurs mines de charbon le
royaume uni qui se targue d'avoir fait
le plus d'efforts en matière de
réduction de la pollution
au final l'union européenne arrive donc
avec une position unie elle propose de
réduire ses gaz à effet de serre de 40%
d'ici à 2030 et de 50% d'ici à 2050 par
rapport aux niveaux de 1990 et voilà
donc l'europe droite dans ses bottes qui
bataillent pour des mesures
contraignantes
au risque de froisser le partenaire
américain
alors nous ont rejoints sur ce plateau
deux invités clôture 9 vous êtes
eurodéputée écologiste du luxembourg à
votre domaine de prédilection c'est le
réchauffement climatique
vous avez aussi à dada c'est les
énergies renouvelables face à vous jean
quatremer qu'on ne présente plus si je
vais le faire quand même à vous est le
correspondant de libération à bruxelles
à dans la capitale européenne vous êtes
l'auteur aussi d'un bloc coulisses de
bruxelles une mine d'informations pour
ceux qui s'intéressent à l'europe donc
on vient de voir le sujet on a entendu
jean claude juncker le patron de la
commission qui dit que cet accord sur le
climat doit être contraignant
est-ce que c'est pas un voeu pieux
sachant qu'il n'y a pas de gendarmes
pour vérifier ou sanctionnés au cas où
les promesses ne sont pas respectées
clôture nas mais le problème c'est que
les états unis et la chine n'accepte
personnes au dessus d'eux donc ils
n'acceptent pas des gendarmes qu'ils
soient des nations unies autres et donc
ça c'était encore à cap copenhague et à
cinq ans on a essayé d'imposer un
gendarme mondial pour vérifier on sait
que politiquement ça va pas fonctionner
face aux états unis à la chine est donc
aujourd'hui on se rabat sur un système
qui doit être le plus contraignant
possible pour que chaque cinq ans les
états du monde doivent présenter les
plans comment arriver à rester dans un
changement climatique qui n'est pas
désastreux la deuxième chose qu'il
faudra vérifier si les flux financiers
promis aux pays en voie de développement
comme moi 1 100 milliards et la
troisième chose qu'il faudra gagner
s'est il faudra mettre au ban tous les
banquiers qui continue à financer le
charbon le pétrole le gaz et donc ça
c'est les trois choses qu'on doit
arriver de faire le plus contre galles
on a posé la contrainte ça va être
possible
la contrainte c'est un mot parce qu'on
sait bien que toute façon même si on a
une autorité mondiale et si un pays
comme la chine ou les états unis ne
restent pas ne respectent pas leurs
engagements
de toute façon vous allez pas envoyer
les divisions blindées pour les obliger
à respecter l'accord donc c'est vraiment
des mots il faut plutôt une prise de
conscience et que chacun s'engage
véritablement à respecter l'accord
faudra se rappeler encore il ya dix ans
il ya 15 ans il y avait des débats à
n'en plus finir pour savoir s'il y avait
un changement climatique ou pas un
réchauffement climatique ou pas
aujourd'hui regardez vous avez encore un
célèbre présentateur de télévision en
france qui a osé faire un livre qui
contestaient le réchauffement climatique
la réalité du changement climatique etc
il s'est fait virer de sa chaîne de
télévision s'est reco aujourd'hui plus
personne ne conteste donc à une prise de
construire les matins pour réussir tous
des c'est peut-être révélateur c'est
tout à fait vous avez tout à fait raison
ça montre aussi la conception des del à
ivato sceptique car society que la
russie donc non vraiment je pense que la
contrainte
ça veut rien dire dans lequel nous ne
sommes pas une fédération mondiale mais
deuxièmement moi je suis plutôt ravis de
voir la prise de conscience
il n'ya pas seulement prise de
conscience qui est massive surtout dans
les villes donc à paris aura une réunion
où il y aura des milliers de maires de
grandes villes du monde entier et donc
lille c'est les villes qui vont définir
les pistes cyclables qui vont définir le
transport public qui vont préparer
l'avènement de la voiture électrique qui
vont être exemplaire sur les bâtiments
et qu'ils sont proches les citoyens donc
les villes bouge
et l'autre chose qui a bougé c'est les
technologies et les coûts des
technologies donc l'énergie solaire
aujourd'hui elle allait beaucoup
beaucoup moins cher donc il ya plus que
qui a 5 ans donc aujourd'hui a plus
aucune raison de ne pas investir
massivement dans le solaire pas
seulement en europe et aux états unis
mais aussi en afrique dans les villages
reculés le l'éolien est une technologie
qui est mature on sait construire des
voitures des voitures qui consomment
très peu aux séquences mais des des
maisons qui sont positives en énergie
donc les technologies sont là les
citoyens sont motivés maintenant il faut
encore un accord politique et surtout
surtout il faut beaucoup plus de
pression sur le monde finances
notre problème c'est que il ya beaucoup
trop de pétrole il ya beaucoup trop de
charbon il faut le laisser sous terre il
faut arrêter les banquiers qui continue
à financer le charbon et le pétrole
mais c'est intéressant ce que vous dites
à propos des villes parce que nous
sommes dans la capitale européenne si
bruxelles capitale européenne
c'est une des villes les plus
embouteillées les plus polluées du monde
occidental
qu'est ce que font les autorités belges
pour changer le mode de circulation à
bruxelles pas grand chose lire s'il ya
bien une ville qui devraient montrer
l'exemple et l'europe s'intéressait à
cette ville
et bien c'est c'est bruxelles bruxelles
n'est pas un exemple tous les matins
vous avez des fils à n'en plus finir
vous avez cinq cent mille quatre cent
mille navetteurs qui viennent dans
bruxelles donc oui les villes montre
l'exemple des villes qu'une ville comme
paris montre l'exemple des villes comme
berlin montre l'exemple
mais toutes les villes ne sont pas
exemplaires et la ville sans doute la
moins exemplaire curieusement c'est la
capitale alors le réchauffement
climatique les spécialistes parlent
d'une augmentation du niveau de la mer
de plus de 2 80 cm d'ici à 2100 c'est
l'europe qui concerne et c'est l'europe
et c'est aussi vous verrez peut-être que
on aura nous en europe par les premiers
réfugiés climatiques parce que si niveau
de la mer monte
si on n'a pas pris des mesures d'ici là
européen les réfugiés et leur opacité
dernière allant d alors et néerlandais
condé digues mais qui sont largement
insuffisant parce que qu'est le problème
des rivières qui n'a pas été réglé
donc il ya toute la côte flamande une
partie de la flandre risque d'être
envahis par les eaux et vous aurez les
premiers mouvements de population chez
nous dire que l'urgence climatique est
plausible ce scénario catastrophe vous
c'est papa ça fait partie enfin claude
le sait bien quoi ça fait partie des
scénarios qui sont envisagées vous
pourrez très bien avoir 10 millions de
réfugiés climatiques
imaginez ce que ça va donner 10 millions
de réfugiés climatiques qui se bat à
travers l'europe avec des ressources en
eau potable qui poseront problème vient
on est mais là on est tout près du
précipice
on va parler du poids des lobbys et
surtout celui de l'industrie automobile
à un frein dans la lutte contre la
pollution
notre reporter françois goulard est
parti enquêter pas très loin d'ici là à
bruxelles enquête sur l' influence du
lobby de l'automobile dans le travail
des eurodéputés et vous allez voir ça
c'est impressionnant entre les
recommandations et des lobbyistes et le
texte final voté par les eurodéputés
c'est parfois du copier-coller regardez
le reportage de france à bout là
bruxelles
derrière les fenêtres de la capitale
belge s'agitent un monde méconnu celui
des lobbyistes
ils sont entre 15 et 30 mille personnes
à travailler ici pour tenter de faire
pression sur les décisions des
institutions europe et olivier o de man
fait visiter aux citoyens ces lieux
d'affluence son ong a même publié un
guide touristique lobby planète et sa
spécialité à lui c'est le monde de
l'automobile
voici l'immeuble berlaimont le siège de
la commission européenne
c'est là où les 28 commissaire travaille
tous les jours et si au numéro 25
c'est le quartier général des lobbyistes
de volkswagen à bruxelles
l'entreprise a déclaré faire travailler
plus de 40 lobbyistes et ils dépensent
plus de 3 millions d'euros par an en
lobbying pour influencer les décisions
européennes
volkswagen mercedes renault psa
les constructeurs ont chacun des bureaux
discret où s'affairent leur équipe de
lobbies et le travail commence d'abord à
l'extérieur du parlement
ici vous voyez le parlement européen est
juste en face il ya ce petit château qui
appartient à la région de bavière dans
ce bâtiment il y a beaucoup d'événements
organisés par l'industrie automobile
les députés leurs assistants des
diplomates des membres de la commission
tous sont invités et se retrouve ici
pour des réceptions réception et parfois
même cadeau pour les députés européens
dominique riquet connais par coeur ses
méthodes
le vice président de la commission des
transports reçoit chaque semaine des
dizaines de sollicitations aujourd'hui
c'est un aller retour pour abou dhabi
tous frais payés offert par une
compagnie aérienne
de plus en charge pour un voyage comme
ça comme conférencier un bon
un peu compliqué la cecab davantage
important que de se faire trimballer en
première classe on a vu restera donc
c'est non des méthodes parfois douteuses
mais pour dominique riquet la présence
des lobbyistes est nécessaire au travail
des députés
on a besoin aussi d'avoir des contacts
avec des représentants de toutes les
organisations de la société d'être
insolent comme les tomates et donc c'est
important qu'on ait des points de vue
différents
à la condition que vous sachiez que le
point de vue exprimé c'est un point de
vue spécifique ne s'est pas la vérité
révélée que on défend une opinion qu'on
défend des intérêts simple information
ou moyen de pression
la frontière est souvent ténue au
parlement ce jour-là un séminaire bat
son plein à la tribune des élus de
droite et des lobbystes côte à côte qui
dissertent sur les bienfaits de la route
lutter contre les énergies carbone sur
la route sans penser au contexte
économique est une mauvaise idée qui
pourrait détruire ce secteur fragile sur
l'écran des images apocalyptiques d'une
europe sans transport routier des
magasins et des pompes à essence vide
la réunion terminée chacun échange sa
carte de visite et vient siroter une
coupe de champagne pour les lobbyistes
rien d'extraordinaire nous sommes
toujours invité donc si on nous invite à
prendre la parole bien évidemment nous
prenons là par la parole mais c'est
vraiment aux députés donc de faire ce
qu'il veut avec l'information
une simple mise en bouche donc pour le
plat principal il faut aller en
commission des transports
là se décident les normes antipollution
pour les véhicules essence et diesel
aujourd'hui la rapporteure écologistes
karima delli présente son texte sur la
mobilité durable et demande une taxation
plus forte sur le diesel
les députés de droite et d'extrême
droite majoritaire se lève et refuse de
voter
au fond de la salle les lobbystes se
frottent line plus que simple spectateur
ils connaissent par coeur le texte de
karima delli ils ont même envoyé par
mail leurs suggestions d'amendements à
tous les députés
vous voyez bien les rapporteurs et vont
proposer à gauche le texte de départ
celui de la rapporteure il propose de
réduire la vitesse en ville à 30 km
heure à droite
l'amendement conseillé par les
lobbyistes la limite de vitesse a tout
simplement disparu et l'amendement des
lobbyistes sera votée telle quelle par
les députés qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'ils orient même des
voeux des choix d'un moment ça veut dire
qu'ils orientent la loi est ce qui est
très grave parce que le but de du
législateur basse et défend l'intérêt
général et sûrement pas dans leur
intérêt
les constructeurs automobiles ont
dépensé l'année dernière 18 millions
d'euros pour faire pression sur les
institutions bruxelloises et leur
investissement au payer le diesel est
toujours moins taxé que l'essence
partout en europe
le scandale volkswagen pourrait
cependant faire bouger les lignes
l'union européenne devrait rendre
obligatoire en 2016
les contrôles antipollution sur route et
non plus en laboratoire sans conteste un
échec pour les loups voilà pour le
reportage de françois goulard question
toute simple claude turmes vous en
rencontrez des lobbyistes vous avez reçu
des cadeaux
bon moi je l'aï celui d'andré parlement
à des règles sur les cadeaux donc on n'a
plus le droit de recevoir des cadeaux
qui sont au-delà de 250 euros
donc ils sont plutôt des cadeaux type
chocolat au petit une bouteille de vin
moi mon expérience je suis là depuis 15
ans le là où le lobbysme est le plus
virulent s'est pas à bruxelles c'est à
berlin c'est à paris c'est à l'autre les
essais souvent les gouvernements qui
sans l'entrée et qui font qu'ils sont
beaucoup plus proches de gens comme fox
fagen que les parlements au européenne
valait donc ce que je demande en temps
quelqu'un qui était à l'ouvragé pour
avoir un registre des lobis à bruxelles
il faut des registre de lobby à paris à
berlin à londres dans toutes les
capitales parce que sinon on va jamais
les citoyens vont jamais comprendre que
l'europe c'est aussi les failles pour le
lobby dans les capi la 4e merci
directives et des lobbys est-ce que
c'est antidémocratique comme l'a dit
dans le reportage
karima delli ou alors c'est le jeu comme
dit dominique riquet c'est une
contribution faut juste être prudent oui
mais je pense que c'est une contribution
il faut être prudent il faut savoir qui
parle voilà il faut identifier et c'est
vrai qu'on a besoin
les députés ils sont pas hors sol ils
ont besoin de savoir ce que pensent les
ong ce que pensent les associations de
consommateurs est ce que pense
industriel c'est absolument nécessaire
sinon on va voir des eaux il faudrait
les mettre dans une espèce de bulle
pendant cinq ans et ils feraient la loi
il serait le bien au nom du sud dans
tous les domaines
je suis désolé un député ne connaît pas
forcément
les contraintes qui pèsent sur le
secteur aérien le secteur de la machine
à laver et ainsi de suite
il faut qu'ils sont en contact mais la
question c'est de la transparence mais
moi je reviens sur la question de
soulevée par claude et je crois que ça
c'est fondamental savez en france on est
là on fantasme ouais les lobbys à
bruxelles c'est l'horreur et c'est parce
qu'il ya parmi eux des fatals à voilà le
pendu par là le principal les
principales le bis à bruxelles se sont
pas les entreprises ce sont les états
dire que la france quand elle parle elle
parle au nom de renault
elle parle au nom d'edf elle parle au
nom d' areva et ils défendent bec et
ongles et là aussi l'europe jean 88 mais
sans une europe fédérale pendant les
essais que le principal qui qui par
exemple
helmut kohl de son temps qui défendent
est par exemple le la golden share du ce
du land de saxe dans volkswagen
il appelait les commissaires en leur
hurlant dessus vous ne touchez pas à
cette golden share le land de saxe doit
garder le contrôle de volkswagen
etc etc donc c'est permanent et dans les
états écoutez aux dernières nouvelles
dans les lobbys gère en france on a
quand même réussi à faire des centrales
nucléaires parce partout sans aucun
débat démocratique sans vote du
parlement grec sait quelles lobby a
frappé derrière le lobby du mondial des
pharmaceutiques le médiator c'est arrivé
au niveau européen où c'est arrivé en
france
les lobbys sont surpuissants ou raison
déjà la serre proviennent les lobbys
c'est pas forcément au parlement
européen où dansaient sur tout mais
c'est aussi les lobbys s'emporte partout
là où les vingt six ans tombe et donc
les décisions européennes se décide
entre la commission européenne le
parlement européen mais aussi les états
membres et donc il faut beaucoup plus de
lumière sur ce que les lobbys font au
niveau national est d'ailleurs faute
wagen le vrai problème de fox wagen
c'est que en allemagne c'est un empire
fait un nom finance dix musées des
fondations d orchestre et ses partis
politiques on va le dire des partis
politiques non et concentré l'étrangeté
syndicats donc il faut vraiment et il
faut arrêter cette su progresser fluence
de certains secteurs économiques
ce sur les décisions politiques et
l'exemple de franck saurat gun ça doit
être
en fait aujourd'hui on doit être
exemplaire pour montrer où en étaient
les failles du système et il faut que
pétition qui circule ouais en fait on va
on essaye en tant que vers d'instaurer
une commission denquête au parlement
surtout si pour voir où en étaient les
failles dans le gouvernement allemand et
dans la commission royale sur la fraude
c'est vraiment très gênant pour nous
c'est que les lasers volkswagen a été
révélé par les américains eric pour ses
incroyables
alors qu'on a quand même les systèmes de
contrôles nationaux système de contrôle
européen il faut que ça soit les
américains qui viennent nous dire
regardez vos entreprises ont fraudé
ça devrait poser question à tout le
monde et de ce point de vue là j'étais
aux états unis il ya dix y as 5
il ya cinq cent mille voitures diesel en
europe
il y en a des millions et des millions
et donc derrière c'est clair il ya le
poids du lobby tu veux défendre le
diesel
ils n'ont fait depuis 35 ans il faut
arrêter cela il faut mettre là la
priorité sur la santé publique
l'air le climat il faut arrêter cette
surpuissance le message est passé
l'actualité c'est aussi l'europe qui
cherche la parade face à la crise des
migrants et la turquie revient donc en
grâce c'est elle qui détient en partie
les clés ankara obtient une relance du
processus d'adhésion à l'union en
échange d'un meilleur contrôle des
candidats au départ c'est le résultat
d'un sommet union européenne turquie on
regarde et on réagit juste après
accolades chaleureuses ahmet davutoglu
et donald tusk
le président du conseil européen mêmes
gestes d'affection avec le patron de la
commission européenne
le premier ministre turc boit du petit
lait au milieu des chefs d'état
européens
le chef du gouvernement turc savoure une
victoire et pour cause
ankara décroche le jackpot mais c'est un
jour historique
une rencontre historique après 11 ans
c'est la première fois que l'union
européenne et la turquie ont un sommet
de cette envergure
cet accord c'est quoi d'abord l'europe
s'engage à relancer le processus
d'adhésion de la turquie à l'union
européenne à faciliter l'accès aux visas
européens pour les ressortissants turcs
et débloque 3 milliards d'euros dette
financière en contrepartie ankara
s'engage à faire plus pour retenir les
migrants sur son territoire
la turquie a un rôle crucial elle
accueille plus de deux millions de
réfugiés syriens engagement à lutter
contre les réseaux de passeurs et aussi
à améliorer les conditions de vie dans
les camps de réfugiés sur son sol un
accord qualifié à bruxelles de gagnant
gagnant
les légitimes dès lors que la turquie
j'ai un effort pour accueillir des
réfugiés
ceux là même qui ne viendront pas en
europe pour aussi protéger la frontière
turque mais également fermé la frontière
entre la turquie et la syrie il est
légitime
la turquie reçoivent une aide de
l'europe pour l'accueil de ces réfugiés
un accord qui fait l'impasse sur les
droits de l'homme la turquie est pointé
du doigt pour ses atteintes à la liberté
d'expression et à la liberté de la
presse
voilà j'ai envie de vous poser cette
question est-ce que c'est pas messieurs
à marcher dupes ou donnent de l'argent
mais garder ces migrants qu'on ne
saurait voir
c'est absolument scandaleuse en train de
se passer c'est qu'en réalité on voit
les européens vérifier par l'arrivée de
quelques centaines de milliers de
migrants freine savoir que la turquie
accueille sur son sol
2 3 millions de réfugiés syriens le
liban c'est un quart de sa population la
jordanie c'est la même chose
et qu'est-ce qu'on fait comme d'habitude
au lieu d'assumer nos obligations
parce qu'après tout le droit d'asile qui
l'a inventé ce sont les européens après
la seconde guerre mondiale qui avons qui
avons inventé la convention de genève
qu'est-ce qu'on fait aux sous traitent
le problème à la turquie en disant qu'à
écouter garder les et on va vous donner
de l'argent
je ne suis pas sûr que c'est comme ça
qu'on arrivera à régler durablement la
crise des réfugiés d'autant plus que les
tous ces mouvements sont lus son but as
des as les crises des crises les guerres
civiles des crises diplomatiques et
qu'il faudrait plutôt s'investir pour
les régler et je la d'année les derniers
éléments et je suis pas sûr que ça met
alors bombardé la série comme on le fait
aujourd'hui comme on l'a bombardé la
libye
hier on va régler la question donc j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une sorte
d'impasse et diplomatique d'un pensée
sécurité à dépenser sur le droit d'asile
sur nos valeurs on se rue en avant sans
réfléchir aux conséquences
c'est d'ailleurs avec françois hollande
nous préparer à papier sur la dérive
sécuritaire du chef de l'état mais moi
je suis terrifiée par ce qui se passe en
france c'est à dire que face aux
attentats vous avez eu la réponse d'un
gouvernement de gauche a été là ces
dérives
effectivement sécuritaire c'est la rita
d'urgence c'est un truc de fou
l'état d'urgence dans le dans le cas de
figure est aussi la crainte que que des
terroristes prennent le chemin des
vignes
c'était le but de dèche c'est qu'on
trouve ces passeports donc infiltrer un
terroriste par une île grecque et
montrer que finalement la plupart des
réfugiés étaient peut-être des
combattants de neige pour nous obliger à
nous méfier de tous les réfugiés est en
fait de créer une crispation identitaire
et de créer du conflit à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne c'est réussi c'est
même si on a deux qui se sont infiltrés
il y en a huit cent mille qui sont
arrivés 200 800 milles il faut quand
même un peu réfléchir et il faut arrêter
de désigner des boucs émissaires comme
nous sommes en train de le faire et je
trouve que l'offre
ans la réponse qui a été faite par le
gouvernement de gauche à la fois de la
sécurité en clair on donne tous les
pouvoirs à la police et l exécutif et on
déclare la guerre à qui j'ai toujours
pas bien compris à qui on va faire la
guerre c'est pas une réponse à mon sens
de la bonne réponse par le gouvernement
de gauche
on va ajouter à mon avis la violence à
la violence jean clôture de la turquie
qui revient en grâce
l'adhésion à l'union européenne relance
est ce crédible
non en fait il faut quand même lire un
peu le détail de l'accord l'europe a
très peu lâché l'argent comme ça non
mais l'argent et les 3 milliards et la
turquie utilisant imminente il ya les
premières sont liées à des projets
concrets de construction d'écoles
vraiment de l'amélioration de l'accueil
des réfugiés en turquie
et je crois que la chose positif de cet
accord que je vais pas et du corps et
c'est que ça ouvre quand même la voie à
une politique des migrations légales et
en janvier on va voir et on espère voir
quelque chose que les verts ont demandé
depuis 25 ans et l'europe doit avoir la
sur les gammes pour les turcs peuple non
pas pour les turcs aussi pour pour tout
le monde qui veut venir vers l'europe
bien sûr il faut un certain contrôle des
frontières mais contrôler les frontières
sans avoir une voie légale des
migrations
ça c'est vraiment tuer les gens dans la
méditerranée et passez donc c'est ce
mandat là il faut arrêter on l'est on ne
les arrêtera pas je veux dire qu' aucun
mur dans l'histoire il faut que les gens
le courage des hommes politiques ça
serait de dire qu'aucun murge amène à
empêcher les gens d'entrer les murs la
plupart des mieux en généralement il est
construit pour empêcher les gens de
sortir je rappelle quand même c'est ça
l'histoire du mur mais en tous les cas
on la construit des murs et ils se sont
tous effondrés les uns après les autres
donc c'est pas comme ça qu'on réglera le
problème mais vous les gens que lui dire
mais quand vas y qu'on va maintenant
vers un système de migration légale où
on donne la possibilité de ne pas
d'abord prendre le risque de traverser
la méditerranée de vendre tout l'argent
que j'ai un passeur je crois que ça
s'est quand même donc dans ce
marchandage qui que je ne vais pas
défendre c'est la lueur d'espoir l'autre
chose sur laquelle je me
désole c'est que ce rapport très d'été
de la commission européenne sur l'état
en fait 2 ou le non état de droit au
turquie au niveau des médias et ça en
fait ils l'ont ils ont retenu
ils n'ont pas mis au moment où avant les
élections et moi je trouve que c'est
quand même incroyable que c'est le
secteur indique que cette europe de
voisinage m'a vraiment un espoir pour
les jeunes turcs le la fille de ma femme
vit avec un jeune turc
il vient d'écoper une ans de prison
potentiel parce qu'il était à taksim
ce jour ce gala ensemble avec des
milliers des centaines de milliers de
jeunes turquie 10 après que erdogan
après tout les milieux manipulation
qu'il a gagné les élections il dit ce
qu'est ce que je fais encore dans ce
pays et donc moi mon appel aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que l'union européenne qu'est
ce que nous faisons en tant que député
pour redonner un espoir à la jeunesse
turque qui veulent pas d'un poutine
erdogan mais qui veulent d'un pays qui
reconnaît les médias las les jaunes a
droit le travail qui est un pays multi
éthique où on arrête d'arc tak tak et
les turcs elle quand même claude que
très rapidement en france
la constitution oblige à un référendum
si la turquie adhère donc un référendum
positif en france c'est juste
inimaginable
donc en clair et auront jamais qu'un
pays musulman de 78 millions d'habitants
rentrer dans l'europe sont simon pays
devient d'un seul coup un grand pays ou
vers la patrie des droits de l'homme et
c'est ce qu'ils ne semblent avoir oublié
ces temps ci donc c'est pas demain la
veille que les français voteront en
faveur de l'adhésion de la turquie et ça
les turcs le cerveau même lauture moss
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
jean quatremer merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation à vous étiez
complémentaire c'est la fin d'europe
hebdo merci de nous avoir suivis
restez avec nous sur les chaînes
parlementaires bye